pots is one of the most common
manifestations of orthostatic
intolerance that we're seeing after
viral infection is really common in
young women it's amazing and I'm
watching edema in the ankles you know
blood their feet turning purple cuz
anything that affects blood flow right
this is all about blood flow the reason
why your heart is suddenly pounding is
that your body is recognizing that your
blood isn't flowing like it needs to and
you're not getting enough oxygen where
it needs to go including to really
important organs like the brain so you
see cognitive impairment you see
dizziness you GI issues because the
blood flow is something really necessary
to digest properly this is
NSU prepare to dominate